you
Elizabeth Blackburn parent Iran's a
laboratory at the University of San
Francisco in California she pioneered
the study of telomeres were the tips of
chromosomes which has since become an
important field of science advancing the
development of cancer treatments and our
knowledge of Aging we think of the
telomeres being a little bit like that
the little cap or the tip at the end of
a shoelace so if you think if the
chromosome as the shoelace and then
there's two little tips at the end and
those seal off the ends and protect
Blackburn grew up in Australia and after
completing her PhD she was keen to find
out more about chromosomes in particular
the ends in the 1970s very little was
known about telomeres there was no sort
of formula for how one could do this
since I had to make it up and so you
know every day was an adventure because
you didn't know which one was going to
be working and then sometimes you'd get
a result her work showed that telomeres
were actually a repeating DNA sequence
this revealed the genetic structure of
the telomere for the first time I
remember taking the x-ray film out of
the fixer having developed the film and
holding it up against this you know dim
red light in the darkroom and seeing
this very very intense spot that
immediately told me that there was a
particular sequence it so right away I
got a lot of information and I knew
right away there was something really
worth looking at and you know little did
I know it's been the next thirty years
of my life or more looking at this same
kind of DNA
when DNA replicates the very end of the
chromosome cannot be copied so falls
away and disintegrates Blackburn's
discovery showed that the telomere
sequence didn't contain DNA that was
crucial to the cell therefore no
essential genetic information is lost
during the process the telomere sequence
is simply to protect the chromosomes
from damage and is otherwise redundant
today Blackburn travels all over the
world including regular visits to the
Curie Institute in Paris when I was a
kid I read about Marie Curie and read
the biographies about the daughter and
Tobias is very sort of evocative place
because well you know this is Marie
Curie's place and I know it's very
affected by reading all about her and
and it really grabbed me as an idea of
why why you'd want to be a scientist